right before Christmas a good guy in red
is coming to theaters with his new
sidekick
Fred why am I here you're in a pg-13
version of Deadpool filtered through the
prison of childlike innocence and nobody
does childlike innocence like you Fred
nobody I need you almost as much as you
need me I don't need you at all me to
untie you once we're done
[Music]
I'm left you're working up I'm sorry
don't get too attached once upon a
Deadpool character for Marvel movies we
are Merkel yeah but you're you know
Marvel license my Fox it's like if the
Beatles were produced by Nickelback it's
music but it sucks oh you were nicer as
a kid rated pg-13 limited engagement in
theaters December 12
hey everybody is Charlie we got a brand
new Deadpool trailer to break down for
Christmas
if you guys have no idea what's going on
I'll explain I've done a couple of
videos about this but they did a
rillette 'it of deadpool shooting a
whole bunch of new footage Princess
Bride style with Fred Savage and Ryan
Reynolds there's a new round of that
imax ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Deadpool related comment on the video so
many sick burns during this I actually
feel like some of the jokes in this work
almost better than some of the jokes
that they had in the final edit of
Deadpool - the whole purpose of this as
you can see was to temporarily for like
a couple weeks release a pg-13 cut of
Deadpool so the families could go see it
but it's only in theaters for like two
or three weeks it's like a very short
time window just through the holidays
starting December 12th they haven't said
whether or not they plan on releasing a
blu-ray home video version of this down
the road either but as you can tell they
spend the entire trailer ripping on
marvel at Fox produced by Nickelback
because the Fox Disney deal is getting
ready to go through there's actually
some cool updates about that too so this
is actually pretty timely so you see a
couple of Andrews Easter eggs in the
background there but if you've never
seen Princess Bride the whole premise of
this is based on them doing Princess
Bride with the Deadpool 2 movie so in
addition to dropping the f-bombs like
there was actually a promo they released
a Deadpool movie that gives no FS
literally there's no f-bombs during the
movie they probably toned down some of
the gore maybe just a little bit but
most of the new footage that they shop
was done guerilla style within the span
of a couple weeks so I actually think
that that Pixar up joke that they
included was from the original version
and it's just deleted material that
didn't make it into the original kind of
Deadpool - because they made it sound
like all the new footage that they shot
recently was just the Fred Savage stuff
but there will be material that you
didn't see in the original cut of
Deadpool 2 but mostly in the form of
deleted scenes that alternate takes
so it will feel a little bit different
so when the movie comes out and I do a
new Easter egg video for it for all the
different stuff I'll try to explain
what's the brand-new stuff that they
just shot and what's just deleted
material from the original version of
the movie that we haven't seen yet but
Princess Bride if you haven't seen it
this is like a short clip of little kid
Fred Savage with Peter Falk doing this
same thing with Deadpool Thanks right
when I was your age
television was called books this is a
special book you have to imagine that
he's probably not duct-taped to the bed
misery style that's a she a Stephen King
joke if you've never seen misery or read
that book it's about an author played by
James Caan who gets into a car accident
and rescued by Kathy Bates in this
remote area turns out she's a super fan
of his riding and ends up trying to trap
him in her house so to keep him from
running away she duct-tapes him to the
bed she also breaks his legs I'm
assuming Deadpool did not break Fred
savages legs because that would kind of
defeat the purpose of making it a pg-13
movie Fred Savage is not a powerful man
it's not like he could get up and
overpower Deadpool and run out the door
but you do notice that they probably got
a bigger bed for this because when they
shot the original movie Princess Bride
he was this really little kid his feet
do reach the foot of the bed but when he
rips the covers off to show that he's
duct-taped to the bed you actually see
that his feet to reach the end so maybe
they're just doing another Deadpool
babylegs joke to make it seem like Fred
Savage has tiny little bitty legs where
wouldn't you cover that up
a warrior has nothing to be ashamed of
how would you do I mean look at you
you're just straight shirt cocking it
toddler style oh yeah
full winnie-the-pooh the hell's
happening describe it I wouldn't ask
gonna do that it's like um here we go
it's like he was giving birth anally but
they quit halfway through they got the
legs out and they said you know what
if you look in the background here on
his headboard this is all made to look
like the bedroom that he had during that
original Princess Bride movie but there
are a couple extra pieces of merchandise
that they pepper in so like you have the
1980s logo on the Cheetos bag but you
see some Deadpool merchandise over here
and there's a Captain America action
figure just another reference to the
Avengers in Deadpool being in the same
universe relatively quickly then they
have the very on-the-nose Nickelback
marble joke it's like the Beatles if it
were produced by Nickelback its music
but it's crap the funny thing about
those jokes like when Deadpool rips on
Fox Marvel and x-men movies is that the
Fox people the executives are totally
down for that they let him do that as
much as he wants there were only a
couple of jokes that they made them
delete out of the Deadpool to cut that
we saw in theaters and one of them was a
really big Disney Mickey Mouse riff but
because the movie was being completed
way before the talks for the Disney Fox
Steel had ever finished and they had
settled on terms the Fox people were
really worried the Deadpool ripping on
Disney so directly would hurt their
chances for the deal going through so
they made Ryan Reynolds get rid of it
there was a news report that just
released this morning while I was
working on this trailer video that China
unanimously approved the Disney Fox deal
and they were one of the last really big
countries around the world that had to
approve it on a business level so they
actually have to get approval from every
country that they operate in around the
world for the most part that's all done
but there's still a couple of hoops that
they have to jump through early next
year so around the time Avengers force
hitting theaters is when the deal is
supposed to complete maybe a little bit
before then but I know a lot of you are
asking if that deal is completed does
that mean that Marvel and Disney can put
x-men stuff in post-credit scenes like
is there anything that they can just
cram in at the last minute and as far as
I know that's not the case they could
technically do it but because most of
the film is done and if they were gonna
do a really big post-credit scene they
wouldn't need to lock it down and decide
on what it was gonna be a long time ago
just because it takes so long to
complete special effects so if you're
hoping for any x-men references or
anything special because of this
crossover deal Kevin Feige has said many
times that they will close Avengers 4 in
a way that will set up the
next phase of Marvel movies so he's kind
of talking around it a little bit like
deals not done I can't say anything
official but we have a lot of ideas
we've been dreaming of this for a long
time right now my level of expectation
for x-men stuff during Avengers 4 is
verbal reference only just implying that
there's an idea of mutants somewhere out
there but beyond that we'll just have to
wait for them to start dropping footage
and the first teaser trailer that they
drop which is supposed to drop in the
next couple of weeks will probably be
like that first infinity war trailer
like there was a lot of moments of them
all coming together you saw the new
costumes but you didn't really get a
sense for the plot so do not be
surprised if that first Avengers 4
trailer is very cryptic but we can break
it down as soon as it drops everybody
let me know what you think of all this
Deadpool stuff in the comments below
this would actually be a really good
promo for them to do when Deadpool is
inside the MCU like you have him kidnap
spider-man and duct-tape him to the bed
or a kidnap Robert Downey jr. and try to
read him a story what'll happen is is
they drop the final Aquaman trailer so
I'll do a video for that Marvel also
revealed a brand new official MCU
timeline so I'll do a breakdown of that
soon too click here for my brand new
Avengers Eternals Marvel phase 4 video
and click here for that brand new
spider-man into the spider-verse
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]